The animal kingdom is full of,
uh,
an amazing,
amazing behaviors typically in which
males are trying to attract females.
Um,
so most of the time through the animal
kingdom,
females are the ones who tend to be very
choosy.
I'm so they pick between different males
based on their attributes in part
because males typically don't donate
much other than their good sperm and
they're good jeans.
Uh,
so females,
females tend to care a lot about your,
how good a male looks you,
how awesome his song is,
how great his dances and so on.
And this leads to a pressure for males
to kind of ratchet it up and have a bit
of an arms race in terms of how awesome
their dances and their song is.
And so on,
some of my favorite examples of a kind
of males ratcheting it up,
um,
our cases of a species known as the buff
breasted Sandpiper.
Um,
it's this otherwise kind of drab looking
Brown Arctic bird.
It's a drab looking because know lives
in the Arctic,
very hard to get food and do everything.
Um,
but it kind of allows for it's beauty to
come out and really strange ways and one
of these ways is that it has an
incredibly attractive armpit.
So it's armpit is very white,
very clean,
and it will do a flash displays for
females were males will kind of get out
in the field and sort of flash it's
armpit.
And if the female like the armpit,
they kind of fly from miles and miles
and then they'll kind of do this
wonderful display,
uh,
in the female's fall for it.
They think this is wonderful,
but you can tell,
you know,
kind of which males have the sexy
armpits by,
you know,
which ones are kind of flashing all the
females were there.
And so on.
Uh,
they're also,
uh,
other species in which males do
incredible dances to move females.
Uh,
there's a species of bird known as a
mannequin in which a males actually do a
really elaborate dancing display.
It actually involves two partners.
So there's a kind of senior male who
gets to mate with the females and
another male who apprentices with him
and has to learn the dance.
And the female picks on the dance of
both of them,
even though the senior guy gets the
girl.
But then eventually the apprentice will
kind of inherit the dancing court and
get the lady.